l'actualité en France 15 ans après le
début de l'affaire Grégory les avocats
des grands-parents de l'enfant assassiné
ont l'intention de demander un
complément d'enquête avec l'utilisation
de test ADN sur les timbres postes des
lettres du corbeau dans l'une
revendiquait clairement le meurtre de
Grégory l'utilisation de ces nouvelles
techniques ultra sophistiquées si elle
est acceptée par le juge c'est une
utilisation pose un certain nombre de
questions
la vérité de l'affaire Grégory se cache
peut-être derrière ce timbre cette
lettre menaçant envoyé au grand-père de
l'enfant porte l'identité du corbeau
dans l'ADN de la salive qui a encollé le
petit carré de papier pour les
scientifiques les obstacles à
l'identification ne sont pas
insurmontables 17 ans après mais il y a
tout de même certaines conditions nous
avons du recul avec des échantillons qui
sont différents qui avaient plusieurs
années près de 10 ans et qui nous ont
donné ils ont permis d'avoir des
résultats avec succès mais nous avons
déjà travaillé sur des échantillons
moins âgés et pour lesquels nous n'avons
pas pu obtenir de résultats certains
membres de la famille avaient gardé
enfouis au fond de leur mémoire cette
pièce à conviction c'est une affaire
marseillaise du même type résolu grâce à
une analyse de salive 14 ans après qui a
fait renaître le folle espoir cette
décision est une décision réfléchie qui
n'est dirigée contre personne et pouvez
pas qu'il y ait la moindre équivoque
là-dessus nous sommes au service de la
vérité et tant qu'il restera un espoir
de voir confondre à travers le corbeau
l'assassin du très Grégory il serait
criminel de ne pas l'intention pour
Christine et Jean-Marie Villemin coupé
aujourd'hui du reste de leur famille
c'est une nouvelle épreuve il redoute
par-dessus tout le réveil des passions
Eden suscitées par l'affaire et ne
veulent surtout pas de nouvelles
polémiques mais leur avocat affirme
s'ils ont la certitude scientifique que
les résultats seront indiscutables alors
il se soumettront aux analyses
tout à fait d'accord et toutes les
mesures permettant d'avancer sur le
chemin de la vérité plusieurs questions
première question faisabilité de
l'expertise ADN est-ce que nous avons le
support est-ce que les salés sont encore
en bon état un scientifique pourra
répondre à ces questions et nous le dira
les époux villeminent une autre
condition que les tests concernent tous
les protagonistes de l'affaire même ceux
aujourd'hui décédé les deux parties on
fait la même demande auprès de la Cour
d'appel de Dijon c'est donc elle qui
décidera ou non de la réouverture du
dossier